en Ukraine on s'interroge depuis des
semaines sur cette contre-offensive
préparée par keV alors imminente ou pas
face aux commentaires nombreux
commentaires et au doute exprimer ces
derniers jours le président
ukrainien velody murzuelinski s'est
enfin exprimé c'était chez nos confrères
de la BBC ce matin il faudra encore
dit-il un peu patienter écouter le
le plus important c'est de protéger
notre peuple nous attendons des
équipements blindés appropriés ils vont
arriver en plusieurs fois et avec ça on
pourra aller de l'avant nous devons
attendre nous avons besoin de plus de
temps
en appelant à la patience le peuple
ukrainien aujourd'hui le patron de
Wagner Prigogine n'y croient absolument
pas lui parler d'un écran de fumée en
réaction il estime que la
contre-offensive reste imminente on va
aller voir du côté de Kiev tout de suite
comment ces propos sont aujourd'hui
perçus trouvent sur place Emmanuel
chasse notre correspondante bonjour
Emmanuel des réactions peut-être déjà
assez propos
bonjour Elisabeth avant tout j'aimerais
souligner que dans son discours on
voulait dire zenki à toucher un point
qui est assez important ici c'est
l'importance de sauvegarder des vies
humaines il a dit on peut bien sûr
continuer on peut bien sûr lancer une
autre enfoncive et on aura sans doute du
succès mais on perdrait beaucoup de
monde et ça c'est inacceptable donc on a
besoin d'attendre on a style on a
toujours besoin de plus de temps ça je
pense que c'est important parce que ça
montre que quel que soit le niveau de
préparation et l'envie de commencer une
action de masse il y a avant tout
quelque chose qui tient vraiment à cœur
ici en Ukraine c'est de faire attention
aux soldats de sauvegarder le plus
possible plus possible leur vie de les
préserver à leur qu'on sait que
l'Ukraine a déjà payé un prix énorme en
matière de vie de soldats au front
ensuite ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
cette déclaration elle a été faite sur
sur un média public on pense bien que si
contre il y avait vous le dire Zelenski
n'irait pas l'annoncer aussi
publiquement donc oui effectivement on
peut se poser la question est-ce que
effectivement l'Ukraine va attendre où
est-ce que c'est une stratégie
rappelez-vous en septembre dernier lors
de la contre-offensive réussie qui avait
mené à la libération de la région de
harkis tout le monde en tout cas d'un
point de vue occidental tout le monde se
préparait avoir de l'action dans le sud
du pays de voir cette contrefondie au
sud et d'ailleurs les porte-paroles de
l'armée avaient avaient sous-entendu que
ce serait le cas donc peut-être que
c'est encore une tactique en tout cas
ici on salue la décision de on salut en
tout cas cette partie du discours de ça
à savoir préserver protéger la vie des
soldats un mot aussi peut-être Emmanuel
s'il vous plaît de secret
d'une certaine forme de lassitude des
occidentaux
exactement en fait depuis le début du
conflit le gouvernement ukrainien Martel
qu'il a besoin d'armes et ce n'est pas
qui ne les obtient pas c'est qui les
obtient au compte-goutte et c'est ceci
qui pose problème les soldats Ukrainiens
sont prêts mais ils n'ont pas forcément
le matériel nécessaire en tant voulu et
comme ce conflit 7 ans s'inscrit dans
une durée que personne souhaite ici il y
a évidemment la crainte la crainte d'une
lassitude du côté
occidental alors volody merzelez qui en
a parlé également dans cette interview à
la BBC il a dit qu'il ne s'inquiétait
pas par exemple d'un éventuel changement
de présidence aux États-Unis si Joe
Biden venait à ne pas être réélu
puisqu'il explique que le soutien dont
dispose l'Ukraine dont bénéficie
l'Ukraine de la part des États-Unis et
be partisan mais c'est vrai qu'ici il y
a évidemment cette inquiétude que
finalement il va y avoir une sorte de
normalisation de cet état de guerre et
que notamment si une côte enfinive n'est
pas justement couronnée de succès et
bien que les pays occidentaux se
lasseront de ce de ce soutien et
tenteront de pousser l'Ukraine vers des
négociations merci beaucoup Emmanuel
chaise en direct de kievin j'ajoute aux
propos de gagner Prigogine patron de
Wagner toujours à barmouth lui estime
que la contre-offensive ukrainienne en
réalité bel et bien déjà commencé dans
la région de darkmoud donc sur le front